Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Neural style transfer is an incredible technique
where we have two input photographs, and the
output would be a combination of these two,
namely, the content of one and the artistic
style of the other fused together.
When the first paper appeared on this topic,
the news took the world by storm, and lots
of speculative discussions emerged as to what
this could be used for and how it would change
digital arts and the video game industry.
It is great fun to use these algorithms and
we have also witnessed a recent proliferation
of phone apps that are able to accomplish
this, which is super cool because of two reasons:
one, the amount of time to go from a published
research paper to industry-wide application
has never been so small, and, two, the first
work required a powerful computer to accomplish
this, and took several minutes of strenuous
computation, and now, less than two years
later, it's right in your pocket and can be
done instantly.
Talk about exponential progress in science
and research, absolutely amazing.
And now, while we feast our eyes upon these
beautiful results, let's talk about the selling
points of this extension of the original technique.
The paper contains a nice formal explanation
of the weak points of the existing style transfer
algorithms.
The intuition behind the explanation is that
the neural networks think in terms of neuron
activations, which may not be proportional
to the color intensities in the source image
styles, therefore their behavior often becomes
inconsistent or different than expected.
The authors propose thinking in terms of histograms,
which means that the output image should rely
on statistical similarities with the source
images.
And as we can see, the results look outstanding
even when compared to the original method.
It is also important to point out that this
proposed technique is also more art directable,
make sure to have a look at the paper for
more details on that.
As always, I've put a link in the video description.
This extension is also capable of texture
synthesis, which means that we give it a small
image patch that shows some sort of repetition,
and it tries to continue it indefinitely in
a way that seems completely seamless.
However, we have to be acutely aware of the
fact that in the computer graphics community,
texture synthesis is considered a subfield
of its own with hundreds of papers, and one
has to be extremely sure to have a clear cut
selling point over the state of the art.
For the more interested Fellow Scholars out
there, I've put a survey paper on this in
the video description, make sure to have a
look!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!